[Music]
[Applause]
good evening everybody is Chris from
Falls my son locksmith and today I'm
gonna be programming a key for a 2015
GMC Sierra Denali we're gonna be using
the auto prepare light
I'm gonna program this be 119 key and
let's get started now the customer lost
the key but luckily he had the key code
tag the original one so I was able to
cut the key by code but I don't have to
pin code so I'm hoping that the auto pro
pad like can bypass it I can read the
pen program the key and get paid and get
the hell on home because it's cold out
here so anyway let's go ahead and get
started
u.s. GM agree to the universal terms
hoping you guys can see cuz it's kind of
dark let me zoom in a little bit let's
go to read security code this is for
technician on all right ignition is on
this is the whole job right here let's
go ahead and see if you can be depend
GMC Sierra there goes the pen 8:05 seven
okay now it's erasing fault codes I
don't know why it's doing that but I'm
gonna let it do what it's doing alright
so let's go ahead and go back back again
one more time just go to immobilizer by
vehicle GMC Sierra 2015 program keys
without smart
or keys lost close old doors for
ignition on or the doors are closed
ignition is on let's go ahead and press
yes code is 80 57 okay
yes that's the right password
communicating all right so it's go
fragran the system please wait about 10
minutes and we're on a countdown right
now right now we're at 10 seconds 11
seconds so I'm gonna go ahead and post
this video and come back when the times
about up all right so we're back we're
at 9 minutes and 40 seconds
should have got the - you know she's a
security light is on solid so let's go
ahead and see what happens it's the
countdowns almost done
Jeff figuring system
open and close which live is door closed
press ok he's already on the opposition
okay
want to program another key no fish
ignition off and remove the key and
press ok
open close the door again
okay looks like we got another countdown
and their light just fell over so
hopefully you can see it's counting down
34 33 32 31 so let's see what happens
this is definitely not my best directive
video that's for sure
it's tough after 12 o'clock at night
10 9 8
Triss ignition on press okay okay not
responding to me
okay program complete okay security
light is off assault mission put it back
on and that's a wrap
programming 2015 GMC Sierra Denali